Oh five-second rule
I just cleaned the floor it's probably
fine right a lot of people swear by the
five-second rule that if you drop a
piece of food and pick it up before five
seconds it hasn't been on the floor long
enough to pick up dangerous bacteria is
that really true find out we're going to
need to do an experiment it's time to
science
[Music]
to figure out if the five-second rule is
true we need to test whether food drop
on the floor for a long time picks up
more bacteria than food dropped on the
floor for a short time we'll start with
a hypothesis food picked up after five
seconds will collect fewer bacteria than
food picked up after 50 seconds but we
have a little problem microbes are much
much too small to see with the naked eye
this makes measuring them a bit tricky
what we're going to have to do is grow
the microbes into colonies large enough
to see to do this we need some sort of
incubator that can maintain a nice warm
temperature of 37 degrees Celsius that
bacteria would happily grow in think you
need a lab to do this nope building a
DIY incubator is simple I built one
based on the home incubators people use
to hatch chicken eggs take a standard
foam drink cooler and cut a small hole
on the side then plug a 25 watt
incandescent lightbulb into the hole as
a heat source to see inside put a piece
of glass for a picture frame into the
top next poke a very small hole near the
bottom and stick a remote digital
thermometer inside to keep tabs on the
temperature finally plug in the light
bulb the phone from the cooler traps
heat in and lets the incubator get nice
and toasty over the next day cut a few
extra holes on the sides as needed to
release some of the heat and keep the
temperature inside exactly where you
want it okay we've got an incubator now
we need an experiment I want to drop
something fun so I chose Bologna we're
gonna use a gel-like substance called
agar to grow our microbes it's made of
algae and full of things that bacteria
like to eat in this experiment I want to
compare Bologna that's been dropped for
five seconds - Bologna that's been
dropped for 50 seconds so I just need
two groups right wrong after all we
don't know how clean our floor is and we
don't know if our food will grow
bacteria on its own in the end I need to
culture six groups I need one where
nothing happened that's my control I
need another with Bologna that was never
dropped to find out if it grows bacteria
on its own then I don't know how clean
the average floor is which means I need
to compare both clean and dirty floors I
got one section of floor as clean as I
possibly could get it I used effing all
to kill anything on the surface the
other had a little fun with I'll drop
Bologna on clean and dirty sections of
floor four five and fifty seconds each
once the auger is firm it's time to
start dropping food keep in mind we want
to keep everything around the experiment
as clean as possible to prevent foreign
bacteria from interfering with our
results wearing gloves in the lab coat
can help I'm also doing my experiment
around a lot of lit candles it's not
because I love romance it's because the
candles draw the air upward which means
fewer bacteria from the air will settle
on my dishes I can't just do one plate
per drop I did a preliminary test to
find out how many plates I need to run
to get accurate data
I found out I'll need to run six plates
per group to get a large enough sample
all right
it's Bologna time
[Music]
now we put our plates in the incubator
and wait every 24 hours for the next
three days I take out my plates and
photograph them then we can use the free
software image J to figure out how many
microbes through into colonies my
results show first that bacteria can
grow anywhere even my clean control
wasn't very clean but they also show
that five seconds just doesn't seem to
matter if you drop your Bologna on the
floor you're going to suffer the
bacterial consequences longer times
might mean more bugs but life finds a
way onto your food I'm not the only
person to debunk the five-second rule
several studies have tested it heck the
Mythbusters even did it and they all
show that once food hits floor microbes
jump on board now keep in mind just
because there's microbes on your food
doesn't mean you're going to get sick
our guts are pretty good at fending off
microbial invaders but it's probably
good to play it safe so if you drop food
on the floor maybe it's best just to let
it lie yeah especially that need more
details to do this yourself check out
the links in the description got ideas
for me to try put them in the comments
thanks very much to Ian Sawyer and
Claire Adrian Tucci for their help with
this project don't forget to subscribe
for more awesome experimental goodness
[Music]